there's a lot for a niche to calculate
right now i think it's this position i
mean this is very interesting because
those two lines you pointed out david
the last line is clearly the more
ambitious line so so yeah so if anish
now plays queen takes knight i think
that shows really good ambition on his
part that he's actually really trying to
take this game and win this game if he
plays the other line it looks like it's
a bit of a cop out to me um i mean also
if i was white i would not want to have
allowed this move in the first place i
mean maybe castling queenside was a bit
premature maybe he should have played
pawn to f3 it's still okay but the
queens are coming off the board and that
is something i'm sure magnus would be
very happy with so this this you know
just to get the danger a little bit less
to his position um
yeah fully agreed the queens are about
to come off either black is going to
take the queen now or white can give up
the queen before it's captured by taking
this knight but the queens are
definitely going to depart and we'll
keep you updated on the material
imbalance that will arise once the
queens do get traded off so what do we
think
anisha is going to play